to defeat covet 19  we must defeat it everywhere we must  focus on the most vulnerable  we must act as a global community  we need new tools diagnostics  therapeutics  vaccines and we need them fast but new  tools alone will not be enough  we need stronger health systems and we  need to ensure that the people  the communities that need them the most  actually  get the new tools at the global fund  we're acutely aware  that covert 19 could reverse hard-won  gains in the fight against hiv  tb and malaria diseases that still kill  2.7 million people a year we know  that when the world comes together  united around a common goal  we can defeat even the deadliest disease  and save  millions of lives there's no time to  lose  we must unite to fight